frau berg heute zum ersten mal im
ausland unterwegs gestern losgeflogen
und zwar strahlenden die welt hinaus es
gibt ein wunderschönes foto wie frau
werben die regierungsmaschine einsteigt
stolz wie bolle sagt man hier in berlin
und ja man muss konstatieren so schick
und so jugendhaft kam die deutsche
außenpolitik noch nie daher weiblich war
sie ihn noch nie jetzt ist sie es jetzt
haben wir da ja jemanden habe annalena
baerbock unsere erste außenministerin
muss nach lebenslauf und auch nach ihrer
buch affäre und nach dem völlig
verarmten wahlkampf contact dieser
cannstatt kandidatur die richtig in die
hose ging muss sie nun zeigen dass sie
es doch kann die gefahr dabei sie hat
schon vorher große töne gespuckt hat
schon vorher ganz klar in richtung
russland und richtung china gesprochen
doch bevor sie überhaupt im amt war
einzig gehört sich dass du nicht und sie
hat sich aus dem umweltministerium auch
die zuständigkeit für das china mit über
geholt das heißt also die deutsche
außenpolitik ist und demnächst auch eine
weltklimapolitik und da ist meine
befürchtung dass die probleme züchtig
verheddern
[Applaus]
werden das natürlich sehr energie der
wir sind voller hoffnung dass herr
scholz möglicherweise als pragmatiker
die moral ist in
die moralisieren freiburg etwas
zurücknimmt ich finde das auch besorgnis
erregenden wir haben in der heutigen
gesellschaft das zeigt auch diese runde
hier sind so viele emotionen in den
diskussionen unter ihnen auch
außenpolitisch werden die gräben
vertieft und als schweizer wenn ich
jetzt auch noch immer eine patriotische
karte spielen darf die schweizer sind
eigentlich daran interessiert dass alle
mit allen reden dass man versucht
irgendwo die us interessen in den
vordergrund zu stellen nicht einfach
diesen moralismus und wir leben heute
und ausgrabungsleiter eine exponenten
moralis tisch verseuchten zeiten sicht
und also der titel hat nicht die
heutigen verlangen
solche sicherheiten und deshalb ist
meine hoffnung dass
freiburg einen realitätscheck erlebt und
sich sozusagen in ihrem amt
möglicherweise in die aufgabe
hineinwächst aber ich möchte da auch in
rücksicht auf ein titel nicht noch
weiter machen sondern im dialog probleme
hier nahm alles über schlimme wochen
alles gut also ich finde sie hat
natürlich jetzt nicht gerade um sehr
freundlich auszudrücken die die reale
qualifikation für deutschlands top
diplomaten ich darf kurz mal in silber
nicht in der lage eigentlich ein buch zu
schreiben sie hat ihren lebenslauf
aufgehübscht das macht man schon gar
nicht mehr hören aber das sind einfach
doch erhebliche verstöße ich würde schon
ein versagen abgeschrieben es war schon
viel das war noch eine schnellst korea
ist richtig buch abgeschrieben und einen
lebenslauf mit verschiedenen
mitgliedschaften diese teilweise
erfunden hat das qualifiziert ein
eigentlich vielleicht maximal für eine
spitzenposition im elternbeirat irgendwo
aber trotzdem ist die latte hier
natürlich so tief gelegt durch herrn
master kann sie eigentlich nur drüber
tänzeln insofern höre ich schon bereit
hier erstmal ist eine chance zu geben
sie kommt jetzt gleich hinein in der das
säurebad der realpolitik wir haben
vielleicht eine kriegerische
auseinandersetzung zwischen zwischen der
ukraine und russland quasi vor der
haustür mit folgen nach polen sie wird
jetzt in warschau ihre aufwartung machen
ich glaube sie wird genau merken dass
sie liefern muss und herr scholz hat vom
anfang thanheiser maß an die kandare
genommen hat gesagt also was mit peking
sein soll was mit china sein soll was
mit russland sein soll jetzt sieht man
schauen ob sie ausbüxt und weil das ist
ein sehr wichtiger punkt uni wie wichtig
ist das außenministerium bearbeiten auch
gerade sagen für mich nimmt das
außenministerium in ähnlichen weg wie es
verteidigungsministerium über viele
jahre falsch besetzt die europapolitik
wird ohnehin im kanzleramt gemacht alle
wesentlichen entscheidungen fallen dort
und das wird irgendwie das war jetzt
heiko maas das wird durch die welt in
einem zu eng geschnittenen anzug und
wird ist dadurch seien auffällig slim
fit und jetzt kommt eine moralisch
aufgeladene sage ich nicht versorgt
sondern aufgeladene
außenministerin die alles das mitbringt
was die grünen über jahre hinweg an
menschenrechtsverletzungen und sonstigen
dingen in der welt kritisiert haben und
die große gefahr ist dass sie versucht
das eins zu eins in praktische politik
umzusetzen das funktioniert natürlich
nicht sie muss lernen diplomatisch
aufzutreten zieht vertritt ja deutsche
interessen dazu gehören auch
wirtschaftsinteressen wenn sie sich
massiv gegen die chinesin wendet wird
als erster ihr parteifreund kretschmann
in stuttgart auf schreien weil der will
autos dahin exportieren und das wird
möglicherweise eine falsche geschichte
mir schwant so langsam dass der
schwachpunkt in dieser dreier koalition
die grünen sein werden und zwar nicht
nur frau bär bockshorn auch nachher
habeck der sich ein riesen ministerium
gezimmert hat dass ihn auch überfordern
könnte das kann er wollte halt mit mit
lindner schritt halten der das
finanzministerium übernimmt und dann hat
er immer noch was drauf gesattelt und da
bin ich mal gespannt er hat ja bisher
nur ein landes wenn es die haben geführt
dass man nicht allzu groß was die beiden
dann daraus machen weil das ministerium
habe ich noch deutlich größer ist ja
deutlich hatte auch in den strukturen
ich glaube das kann man letzten endes
auch nicht komplett nach unten rocken
also ihr haben wir haben da sagen wir
haben die haben aber heute den fehler
gemacht wenn man gesehen hat wenn sie
mitgenommen haben in ihrem ministerium
das waren so grüne
zugs figuren die sie da mit irgendwie
auch was werden und ich habe nicht die
anstrengung gesehen die besten zu holen
neben einen grünen nationalheld ist und
ihm völlig wurscht welcher partei er
angehört
ja wenn da nicht noch was sagen kann zu
meiner these ich glaube schon dass
robert diese chance hat sie die auch
einer der gründe hat den habe ich auch
genannt das ist heiko maas wir hatten
einen außenministerium und wir hatten
einen außenminister hatten war
außenpolitik sie hat nicht stattgefunden
die konvergierte westerwelle gab es nach
außenpolitik da haben wir auch sachen
fall verweigerte haben wir uns auch in
kontroversen rein begeben und die chance
ist dass wir natürlich auch eine andere
ansprache auch gegenüber china
hinkriegen aber die muss so sein dass
man das auch durchhalten kann das ist
das problem man kann sich nicht
hinstellen und hohen mauern aufbauen
wenn man es dann nicht halten kann und
ich glaube dass es ihr gelingen kann ich
befürchte dass es nicht ganz gelingen
wird aber ich gebe ihr tatsächlich mal
eine chance auf die frau sowie
niedergeprasselt auch von uns auch von
mir man muss ihr die chance geben die
100 tage verdient ich fand den auftritt
heute den sie den den sie hatte die fand
ich grundsympathisch war keine krise bei
aber zumindest wenn wir das dann noch
fahren können wenn dann tatsächlich auch
noch ein bisschen härter mit dazu kommt
aber mit verstand und zu gesprächskanäle
offen halten weiß nicht was für beide
heute und wir haben aber
gesprächskanäle die sind ja nicht von
unserer seite aus treibstoff sondern die
werden von moskau aus verstopft die
darwin kriege geführt die werden vor
allem von china aus verstopft eigentlich
wenn uiguren dort in
konzentrationslagern gehalten werden
wenn die zwangssterilisiert werden wenn
bestimmte sachen gemacht meine
befürchtung ist einfach die wenn ich
jetzt deutschland deutsche aber nicht
zurückschauen die 2000er jahre 2001 22
war deutschland der kranke mann europas
wirtschaftlich und wenn ich jetzt
schauen wo die wirtschaft sich hinbewegt
in deutschland dann sehe ich ähnliche
entwicklungen auch mit der
energiepolitik und möglicherweise und
das wäre brandgefährlich wenn jetzt frau
bei herr buck diese ganze moralismus in
der außenpolitik sozusagen eine
überkompensation wäre für diese
wirtschaftliche schwäche die sich
angekündigt also wirtschaftlich geht man
runter aber man spielt sich gleichzeitig
als moralische super power auf das wäre
eine gefährliche entwicklung und ich
hoffe nicht dass deutschland